sustainability is a key issue foreign
has a bushing valve will have to
remember that beer is a natural product
we use a lot of natural ingredients it's
a craft product it has been no social
fabric for many years and generations
and we feel it's our obligation as a
company to work in the environment that
surrounds us our dream is a company is
to be the best for your company in a
better world you have two parts to it
the best beer company the better world
and both interact or complementary and
very important the best for your company
is all about brewing the best quality
beers in the world it's all about
attracting the very best talent to be
able to do that it's all about the
ownership culture that we have and the
pursue of this dream in doing old is in
a very efficient manner the better world
it's all about the realization the fact
of the matter that our consumers and
customers and our people and ourselves
we live in communities and because of
that we need to constantly interact with
the outside stakeholders that surround
our business and we divided our better
world efforts and three pillars
basically the first one is about
responsible enjoyment of our products
that's key because again our sense of
purpose is to to brew the best quality
beers for the very finest moments in
life when you're celebrating having good
times and bringing people together the
second pill is about the environment I
mean we draw our raw materials from the
environment special water so for us it's
very important to minimize any impacts
that we have in environment and that's
why that's the second pill of the whole
part of all the environment and just
this year it's months ago we came out
with global targets for the next three
years and three things three pillars one
is water consumption we're committed to
reduce water consumption by almost
twenty percent from the levels we have
today and come to three and a half
liters per liter of beer produced by the
end of the year 2012 the second one is
on heat and energy consumption and
therefore carbon emission reduce it by
ten percent next three years
and the third one it's about the
recyclability of all my products today
we send a 98-percent we want to get to
99 percent so again that's the second
pillar and the third pillar is the whole
thing about community involvement again
our customers our people our consumers
live in communities and we have to care
for those communities and work together
with them and issues that in which we
can help because that's just the right
thing to do and it's also good for the
business
you
I think sustainability is one of those
things that if you can get to it in a
win-win type situation that's the best
way so if you can do it because it's not
only the right thing to do but it makes
business sense then you can be clear
it's not going to be a fad it's not
going to be a one or two-year program
it's going to be a way to manage your
business a way to manage your
interaction with the outside
stakeholders and that's the way you look
at it so we talked about the three
pillars because they are an integral
part of our business and sustainability
of our business going to the future the
day our people our consumers and our
customers they want to know where we
stand in issues like water consumption
heat consumption energy consumption and
recyclability of my products and we've
always been there we've always done it
because we always thought it was the
right thing to do and it was good for
the business now we're being more vocal
about it because the wolf has evolved
consumers have evolved and they want to
know more specifics about where we stand
and the journey on which you are so we
always recognize that we can do things
much better than we're doing today
that's why the motor of our company is
always about opening apps and closing
gaps in order to do that where I was
looking for internal benchmarks external
benchmarks to be able to know what's
best in class where we stand there for
establishing a gap and the whole duty of
management is really establish those
gaps and then look of ways and learnings
and best practice to close those gaps on
everything on the best of your company
and also in the better world part of our
dream
you
I think it's important to say that the
way we work what makes our company what
we stand for is what we call our dream
people culture our dreams to be the best
beer company in a better world we can
only achieve that by having the best
people tracking the very best talent
retaining deploying developing training
these people because everything we do
it's all dependent on the kind of people
and talent we have in the company and
the culture piece it's all about this
ownership culture so this idea that you
own your business that you don't have to
ask this question about what about if I
had my own business this is your
business and we try to foster an
environment where people really believe
and act as owners in our company and
they stay in our company for a long
period of time we love to have people
here that stay for 20 years 30 years
because we think that's the true test of
ownership when you live with the
consequences of your decisions getting
bad you know because there's always a
risk and a decision so because people
dream and culture is such a central
element of what we stand for that's the
whole the whole thing I mean people are
people because they bought into the
dream and because they understand that
they own the business they always trying
to look for best practices benchmarks
internally outside because they
understand that the only way to keep
getting the company to the next level is
by opening those gaps and closing those
gaps because we do it not only because
the right thing to do but because it
makes business sense let's see this
being with us for a long period of time
I think the other thing that also is
very important for us is the long-term
view I mean again that'll has to do with
ownership our people take a long-term
view of our business so we avoid
shortcuts we avoid things that are fats
we're interesting things that really
built a great company and we understand
that this is a journey it takes time and
patience to build a great company but
that's where we had it that's where
we're in business for
you